l'autorité le territoire et le travail
voici les trois grands thèmes du
programme de xavier bertrand candidat
pour représenter le parti les
républicains aux élections
présidentielles il s'est rendu au
théâtre gérard philipe de saint cyr
l'école ce jeudi 4 novembre
objectif présenter son projet et
échanger avec les militants mettre fin à
l'impunité les peines minimales
obligatoires quand on s'en prend
physiquement un policier quand on s'en
prend à un les pompiers quand on s'en
prend à un maire et puis sur le pouvoir
d'achat la prime au travail que
quelqu'un qui travaille à temps complet
nous reçoive pas moins de 1500 euros
quelle que soit sa situation de famille
pour récompenser le travail la justice
aujourd'hui en france elle frappe avant
tout ceux qui travaillent et ça c'est
pas normal je vais mettre un terme un
congrès les républicains pour se ranger
derrière un représentant unique aux
élections présidentielles ils sont cinq
candidats à se disputer la place et
xavier bertrand valérie pécresse michel
barnier eric ciotti et philippe juvin
chacun pourra venir s'exprimer dans les
yvelines c'est pas une primaire c'est un
vrai congrès c'est à dire c'est une
course avec un premier deuxième et
troisième à quatrième donc le premier
j'espère celui qui celui ou celle qui
sortira aura les meilleures propositions
et et on se rangera derrière lui ou
derrière elle pour pour faire campagne
et gagner parce qu'on a une vraie chance
de gagner une centaine de personnes a
participé à la réunion publique pour les
militants pas facile de choisir beaucoup
sont indécis les attendent les
propositions des candidats je pense qu a
pas beaucoup de gens qui sont très
décidée ce qui est intéressant au
contraire c'est que ça permet justement
que les gens se posent vraiment réfléchi
écoutez tous des différents débats pour
que pour que je puisse le 4 décembre
décider quel sera le candidat le
le plus intéressant et qui sera apte de
de se présenter à la présidentielle
seuls les adhérents l air pourront
participer au congrès il se déroulera en
ligne du 1er au 4 décembre prochain